you know I had a big argument with Sarah
about time she's like no time time
doesn't exist I'm like no no time does
exist and now and as as she realized
that her conception of assembly Theory
and my conception assembly Theory were
the same thing necessitated us to
abandon the fact that time is eternal to
actually really fundamentally question
how the universe produces commentarial
novelty so so time is fundamental for s
Theory um I'm just trying to figure out
where you and Sarah converged so I I
think assembly theory is fine in this
time right now but I think it helps us
understand that something interesting is
going on so there's and I've been really
inspired by a a guy called Nick gizen
I'm going to butcher his argument but I
love his argument a lot so I hope he
forgives me if he hears about it but
basically um if you want free will time
has to be
fundamental and we can go at and um if
you want time to be
fundamental
um you have to give up on platonic
mathematics and you have to use
intuitionist mathematics by the by the
way um and again I'm going to butcher
this but basically
Hilbert said that you know infinite
numbers are allowed and I think it was
Brower said no you can't all numbers are
finite so they kind of like we so let's
go back a step because I was like people
going to say assembly Theory seems to
explain that commentor large
commentarial
space um allows you to produce things
like life and technology and that large
commentarial space is so big it's not
even accessible to a Shan Caroll David
Deutsch
Multiverse the physicist saying that um
that all of all of universe already
exists in
time is
probably
provably that's strong
word not
correct that we are going to know that
the universe as it stands the present
the way the present builds the future so
big the universe can't ever contain the
future and this is a really interesting
thing I think Max techmark has this
mathematical Universe he says you know
the universe is kind of like a block
universe first and I apologize to Max if
I'm getting it wrong but people think
you can just move you have the stat you
have the initial conditions and you can
run the Universe um right to the end and
go backwards and forwards in that
universe that is not correct yeah let me
load that in the universe is not big
enough to contain the future yeah that's
why that's it that that's another that's
a beautiful way of saying that time is
fundamental yes and and that you can
have and that's what this is why um the
ex the law of the excluded middle
something is true or False only works in
the
past is it going to snow in New York
next week or in Austin you might in
Austin say probably not in New York you
might say yeah if you go forward to next
week and say did it snow in New York
last week true or false you can answer
that question the fact that the law of
the excluded middle cannot apply to the
Future explains why time is
fundamental well I mean that that's a
good example intuitive example but it's
possible that we might be able to
predict you know whether it's going to
snow if we had perfect information I I
think we you're saying not
impossible impossible so here's why yeah
I'll make a really quick argument and
this argument isn't mine it's it's
Nick's and and a few other people can
you can you explain his view on
fundamental on time being fundamental
yeah so I'll give my view which kind of
resonates with his but based basically
um it's very simple actually it would
say that free will that your ability to
design and do an experiment uh is
exercising Free Will so he used that
thought process I never really thought
about it that way um and that you
actively make
decisions I do think that I used to
think that Free Will was a kind of kind
of consequence of just selection but I'm
kind of understanding that human Free
Will is something really
interesting um and he very much inspired
me but I think that what Sarah Walker
said that inspired me as well that that
um these will converge is that I think
that the Universe in the universe is
very big huge MH but
actually the only the place that is
largest in the universe right now the
largest place in the universe is Earth
yeah I've I've seen you say that and boy
does
that that's a that's an interesting one
of process what do you mean by that
Earth is the biggest place in the
universe because we have this coment
toal scaffolding going all the way back
from Luca so you've you've got cells
that can self-replicate and then you go
all the way to terraforming the Earth
You' got all these architectures the
amount of selection that's going on
biological selection just to be clear
biological evolution and then you have
multicellularity then animals and
abstraction and when abstraction there
was another kick because you can then
build architectures and computers and
cultures and language and these things
are the biggest things exist in the
universe because we can just Build
architectures That Couldn't naturally
arise anywhere and the further that
distance goes in time and this kind of
it's just it's gigantic MH and from a
complexity perspective yeah okay wait a
minute but I mean I know you're being
poetic but how do you know there's not
other earth like uh like how do you know
you're you're basically saying Earth is
really special it's awesome stuff as far
as we look out there's nothing like it
going on but how do you know there's not
nearly infinite number of places where
cool stuff like this is going on I agree
and I would say I I'll say again that
Earth is the most gigantic thing we know
in the universe commentor we know we
know now yeah now I guess this is just
purely a guess I have no data but other
than hope well maybe not hope maybe no I
have some data um that every Star in the
sky probably has planets Y and life is
probably emerging on these planets but
this the amount of contingency that is
associated with life is that I think the
commentarial space associated with these
planets is so different we are never
going to our causal cones are never
going to overlap or not easily and this
is the thing that makes me sad about
alien life why it's why we have to
create alien life in the lab as quickly
as possible because I don't know
if we are going to be able to be able to
build um architectures that will
intersect with alien Co intelligence C
and architectures intersect you you know
I mean in time or space time and the
ability to communicate the ability to
communicate yeah my biggest fear in a
way is that life is everywhere but we
become infinitely more lonely because of
our Scaffolding in that commentarial
space because it's so big and so so
you're saying the the constraints
created by the environment that led to
the factory of darwinian
evolution are just like l a little tiny
cone in a nearly Infinite combinatorial
Space and so there's other cones like it
and and why why can't we communicate
with other like just because we can't
create it doesn't mean we can't
appreciate the creation right like that
sorry detect the creation I I I truly
don't know but I it's an excuse for me
to ask for people to give me money to
make a planet simulator yeah right if I
can make with a different I'm like
another Shameless say it's like give me
money I need money this was all long
plug for a planet simulator it's like
you know hey I will be the first in lie
to my my my U my Rick my Rick garage has
run out of room you know yeah no um and
is this is a planet simulator you mean
like a different kind of planet or
different sets of environments and
exactly if we could basically recreate
the selection before biology as we know
it that gives rise to a different
biology we should be a to put the
constraints on where to look in the
universe so here's a thing here's my
here's my dream yeah my dream is that by
creating life in the lab based upon
constraints we understand like let like
go for Venus type life or earth type
life or something again do earth 2.0
screw it let's do earth 2.0 and Earth
2.0 has a different genetic alphabet
fine that's fine different um protein
alphabet fine have cells and evolution
all that stuff we will then be able to
say okay life is a more General
phenomena selection is more General than
than what we think is Con the chemical
constraints on life and we can point the
James web and other telescopes at other
planets that we are in that zone we are
most likely to con combinatorially
overlap with right so because you know
we Bas so there you're looking for some
overlap and then we can then basically
um shine light on them literally and
white look at light coming back and
apply Advanced assembly Theory to Lang
general theory of language that we will
get and say hauh we in that signal it
looks random but there's a copy number
oh this random set of things that
shouldn't be that looks like a a true
random number generator has
structure as a not com not Kolarov AIT
type structure but evolutionary
structure given by assembly Theory and
we start to um but I would say that cuz
I'm a Shameless assembly theorist yeah I
it just feels like the the cone and may
be misusing the word cone here but the
width of the cone is growing
faster um is growing really fast to
where eventually all the con's
overlap even in a very very very large
combinatorial space
I it
just but then again if you're saying the
universe is uh also growing very quickly
in terms of possibilities that's really
I hope that as we
build as we build
abstractions the main I mean one one
idea is that as we go to
intelligence intelligence allows us to
look at the regularities around us in
the
universe and and that gives us some
common grounding to to discuss with
aliens and and you might be right that
that there we will overlap there even
though we have completely different
chemistry literally completely different
chemistry um um that we will be at pass
information from one another but it's
not a given and um you know I have to
kind of try and divorce hope and emotion
you know away from what I under I
logically justifying but it's just hard
to Intuit it a world a universe where
there's nearly infinite complexity
objects and they somehow can't detect
each other but universe is expanding but
the nice thing is I would say I would
look you see I think Carl Sean did the
wrong well not the wrong thing he he
flicked the Voyager PRO brand and pale
blue dot said look how big universe is I
would have done it the other way around
said look at the voyage of prob that
came from the planet Earth that came
from Luca look at how big Earth is MH
that It produced that It produced that
yeah and that I think is like completely
amazing and then that should allow
people on Earth to think about well
probably we should try and get um causal
chains off Earth onto Mars onto the moon
wherever whe it's human life or Martian
life that we create it doesn't matter um
but but I think um this commentarial
space tells us something very important
about the Universe um and and that I
realized assembly theory that the
universe is too big to contain
itself and and I think this is and I'm
coming back and I want to I want to kind
of change your mind about time because
I'm I'm guessing that your uh time is
just um coordinate yeah so I'm I'm going
to change your I'm guessing you're one
of those I'm going to change your one of
those I'm going to change your mind in
real time or at least attempt oh in real
time there you go um I already got the
tattoo so this is going to be
embarrassing if you change my mind but
you can just add you can just add an AR
Arrow time onto it
true or erase it a bit so um and the
argument that I think that is really
most interesting is like people say the
initial
conditions um specify the future of the
universe okay fine let's say that's the
case for a moment now let's go back to
Newtonian
mechanics now the uncertainty but
principle in newtonium mechanics is this
if I give you the coordinates of your of
an object moving in
space and the coordinates of another
object and they Collide m in space and
you know those initial conditions you
should know exactly what's going to
happen mhm however you cannot specify
these coordinates to infinite Precision
now everyone said you know oh this is
kind of like you know um the chaos Siri
argument no no it's deeper than that
here's a problem with numbers this is
how this is where Hilbert and Brower
fell
out
um to have the coordinates of this
object a given object as a colliding you
have to have them to infinite Precision
that's what Hilbert says it says no
problem infinite Precision is fine let's
just take that for granted but when the
object is finite and it can't store its
own coordinates what do you do
MH so in principle if a finite object
cannot be specified to infinite
Precision in principle the initial
conditions don't apply well how do you
know it can't store its uh
well how do you store an infinitely long
number in a finite size
well we're using Infinity very Loosely
here no no we're using infinite
Precision I mean not Loosely but very
precisely so you think infinite
Precision is required well let's let's
take the object let's say the object is
a a golf ball mhm golf ball is a few
centimeters in diameter we can work out
how many atoms there are in the golf
ball and let's say we can store numbers
down to Atomic dislocations mhm so we
can work out how many atoms there are in
the golf ball and we can store the
coordinates in that golf ball down to
that number but beyond that we can't
let's make the golf ball
smaller and and the this is where I
think that we think that we get
Randomness in quantum mechanics and some
people say you can't get Randomness
quantum mechanics deterministic but ah
this is where this is where we realize
that classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics suffer from the same
uncertainty principle and that is the
inability to specify the the initial
conditions to a precise enough degree to
give you determinism the universe is
intrinsically too big and that's why
time exists it's non-deterministic
looking back into the past you can look
at the you can use logical um arguments
because you can say was it true or false
you already
know but this is the fact we are unable
to predict the future with the Precision
is not EV of lack of knowledge it's
evidence the universe is generating new
things okay so to you first of all
quantum mechanics you can just say
statistically what's going to happen
when two golf balls hit each other
statistically but that but but sure I
can say statistic what's going to happen
but then what they do happen yeah and
and and you keep nesting it together you
can't I mean goes almost back to look at
look at look at um let's think about
entropy in the universe so how do you
what how do we how do we understand um
entropy change well we could do the look
at or process we can use the aeric
hypothesis um we can also have um um um
we can also have the uh counterfactuals
where we have all the different states
and we could even put that in the
Multiverse right but both those are kind
of they they're they're
non-physical uh the Multiverse kind of
collapses back to the same problem about
the Precision so all the the what you if
you accept you don't have to have true
and false going forward into the future
um the real numbers are real they're
just they're just they they're
observables I'm trying to see exactly
where time being fundamental sneaks in
and this difference between that the the
the golf ball can't
contain its own
position perfectly precisely
if how that leads to time needing to be
fundamental let me I have what do you
believe do you believe or do you accept
you have free
will yeah I think at this moment in time
I believe that I have free will so then
you are then you have to believe that
time is
fundamental I understand that's a stable
you've made well no that we can
logically follows because if you don't
have free will so like if you're in a if
you're in a universe that has no time
universe is deterministic if it's
deterministic then you have no free will
I I think the space of how much we don't
know is so vast that saying the universe
is deterministic and from that jumping
there's no free will is just too
difficult of a leap no I logically
follows no no I I don't disagree it's
not I'm not saying any I mean it's deep
and it's important all I'm all I'm
saying and it's the difference of it's
actually different to what I've said
before
is that if you don't require platonistic
mathematics and accepts that that
non-determinism is how the universe
looks and that gives us our creativity
and the way the universe is getting
novelty it's kind of really deeply
important in assembly Theory because
assembly Theory starts to actually give
you a mechanism why you go from boring
time which is basically initial
condition specify everything to a
mismatch in Creative time and I hope
we'll do experiments I think it's really
important to I would love to do an
experiment that prove that time is
fundamental and the universe is
generating
novelty um I don't know all the features
of that experiment yet but by you know
having these conversations openly and
getting people to think about the
problems in a new way better people more
intelligent people with good
mathematical backgrounds can say oh hey
I've got an idea i' would love to do an
experiment that that shows that the UN
Universe I mean universe is too too big
for itself going forward in time and and
I really you know this is why I I really
hate the idea of the boltzman brain the
boltzman brain makes me super kind of
like you know everyone's having a free
lunch it's like saying it's like let's
break all the laws of physics so a
boltzman brain is this idea that in a
long enough Universe a brain will just
emerge in the universe as conscious
without and that neglects the causal
chain of evolution that required to
produce that brain and this is where the
comp computational argument really falls
down because the computation is can say
I can calculate the probability of a
boltson brain and I can and they'll give
you probability but I can calculate
probability of bolman brain zero just
because the the the space of
possibilities is so large yeah it's like
when we start falling ourselves with
numbers that we can't actually measure
and we can't ever conceive of I think it
I think it it it it it doesn't give us a
good explanation and I've become I want
to explain why life is in the universe I
think life is actually novelty minor no
I mean life basically mines novelty
almost from the future it makes it
actualizes in the
present okay life is a novelty
minor uh from the future that is
actualized in the present
yeah I think novelty minor first of all
novelty what's the origin of nov novelty
when you go from boring time to creative
time where is that is it as simple as as
Randomness like you're referring to um I
I am really struggling with Randomness
because I had a really good argument
with yashab bar about Randomness and he
says said Randomness doesn't give you
free will that's insane because You'
just be random but I think and I think
he's right at that level yeah but I
don't think we I don't think he is right
on another level and it's not about
Randomness it's about it's about
constrained I'm going to sound like
constrained opport I'm making this up as
I go along so making this up constrained
opportunity so what I mean is like so
you have to have so that the novelty
what is novelty you know this is why I
think is the funny thing you ever want
to discuss AI why I think everyone's
kind of gone AI mad is that they're
misunderstanding um novelty but let's
think about novelty you ask what is
novelty so I think novelty is a a
genuinely new configuration that is not
predicted by the P past right and that
you discover in the present right and um
that is truly different right now
everyone says that some people say that
novelty doesn't exist it's always with
precedent I want to do experiments that
show that that is not the case and it
goes back to a question you asked me a
few moments ago which is where is the
factory yeah right because I think the
same mechanism gives us a factory gives
us novelty and I think that that is that
is why I'm so deeply hung up on time I
mean of course I'm wrong but how wrong
and I and I think that that life opens
up that commentarial space in a way that
the the our current laws of physics or
the as contrived in a deterministic
initial condition Universe even with the
get out of the Multiverse David deuts
style which I love by the the way but I
don't think is
correct um but it's it's it's kind it's
really
beautiful Multiverse the the David
Deutsch's conception of the Multiverse
is kind of like given um but I think
that the problem with wave particle
duality and quantum mechanics is not um
about the Multiverse it's about
understanding how determin the past is
well I don't just think that actually
this is a a discussion I was having with
Sarah about that right she was like oh I
think we we' been debating this for a
long time now um about how we how do we
reconcile
novelty determinism
indeterminism so okay just to clarify
you both you and Sarah think the
universe is not
deterministic uh I'm I won't speak for
Sarah but I roughly I I think that the
Universe I think the universe is
deterministic looking back in the p back
in the past right but undetermined going
F going forward in the future so I'm
kind of having my cake and eat it eating
it here this is because I fundament
don't understand Randomness right as
Yasha told me or other people told me
but if I adopt a new view now which
um the new view is the universe is just
non-deterministic but I'd like to refine
that and say the universe appears
deterministic going back in the past but
it's but it's undetermined going forward
in the future so how can we have a
determinist a universe that has
deterministically looking rules that's
non-determined going in the future it's
this breakdown in Precision in the
initial conditions and we have to just
stop using initial conditions and start
looking at
trajectories and how how um the comori
space behaves in expanding Universe in
time and space and assembly Theory helps
us quantify the transition to biology
and biology appears to be novelty mining
because it's making crazy stuff M you
know um that we are unique to earth
right there are objects on Earth that
are unique to Earth they will not be
found anywhere else because you can do
the commentarial
math uh what was that statement you made
about life is novelty mining from the
future yeah what's the what's what's the
little element of time that you're
introducing that so what I'm kind of
meaning is because the future is bigger
than the present yeah in a deterministic
universe how do you go from the how do
how do the how do the States go from one
to another I mean there's a mismatch
right yeah so so that must mean that you
have a little bit of indeterminism
whether that's Randomness or something
else I don't understand I want to do
experiments to formulate a theory to
refine that as we go forward that might
help us explain that and um and I think
that's why I'm so um determined to try
and crack the the non-life toli
transition looking at at networks and
molecules and that might help us think
about it the mechanism but certainly the
future is bigger than the past in in my
conception of the universe and some
conception of the universe and by the
way that's not obvious right that's what
was just kind of the future being bigger
than the
past well that that's one statement and
the statement that the universe is not
big enough to contain the future is
another statement yeah yeah yeah yeah I
that one is a big one I that one's a
really big one I think so I think but I
think it's
entirely because look we have the second
law and right now I mean I'm we don't
need the second law if the future's
bigger than the past it follows
naturally right so why are we
retrofitting all these these sticking
plasters onto our reality to hold on to
a Timeless Universe yeah but that's
because it's kind of difficult to
imagine the universe
that's that can't contain the future but
isn't that really exciting it's very
exciting but
it's it's hard uh I mean we're we're are
humans on Earth Earth and we have a very
kind
of four-dimensional conception of the
world of 3D plus time it's just hard to
Inuit it a world where what does that
even mean a universe that can't contain
the
future yeah it's kind of it's kind of
crazy but obvious weird I mean I suppose
it sounds obvious yeah if it's true but
the nice thing is you can so what I I
mean so the reason why assembly Theory
turned me onto that was that you let's
let's just start in the present and look
at all the complex molecules and go
backwards in time M and understand how
evolutionary processes go gave rise to
them it's not in it's not at all obvious
the taxo which is a complex one of the
most complex natural products produced
by biology was going to be invented by
biology it's a accident you know taxo is
unique to Earth there's no taxo
elsewhere in the universe and taxo was
not decided by the initial conditions it
was decided by this kind of the this
interplay between the so the past simply
is embedded in the present it gives some
features but why the past doesn't map to
the Future one to one is because the
universe is too big to contain itself
that gives space for creativity novelty
and and un some things which are
unpredictable well okay so given that
you're disrespecting the power of the
initial conditions uh let me ask you
about so how do you explain that
cellometer are able to produce such
incredible complexity given just basic
rules and basic initial conditions I
think that that you you this falls into
the Brower um Hilbert trap MH so how do
you get a cellular autometer produced
complexity you have a computer you
generate a display and you map the
change of that in time mhm there are
some Casa repeat like functions like
it's fascinating to me that for pi there
is a there is a Formula where you can go
to the the millionth decimal place of Pi
and read out the the the number without
having to go there but there are some
numbers where you can't do that you have
to just crank through MH this um whether
it's wol framan computational
irreducibility or some other thing might
doesn't matter but these
CA that complexity is that just
complexity or number that is basically
you're mining that number in time mhm um
you know is that just a display screen
for that number that function well can't
you say the same thing about the
complexity on Earth then no because the
complexity on Earth um has a copy number
and an assembly index associated with
that that CA is just a number
running you don't think it has a copy
number wait wait a minute well it it
does in the human where where we're
looking at humans producing different
rules but then it's nested on selection
so those CA are produced by selection
yeah I mean the ca is such a a
fascinating pseudo complexity generator
what I would love to do is understand um
quantify the degree of surprise in a CA
write it long enough MH but what that I
guess that means is we have to
instantiate we have to have a number of
experiments where we're generating
different rules and running them time
steps but oh got it ca on mining novelty
MH in the F from the you know in the
future by iteration right and you're
like oh that's great that's great you
didn't predict it some rules you can
predict that what's going to happen
other rules you can't so for me if
anything CA are evidence that the the
universe is too big to contain itself
because otherwise you'd know what the
rules are going to do forever
more right I guess you were saying that
the
physicist saying that all you need is
the initial conditions and the rules of
physics uh is somehow missing the bigger
picture and yeah and you know if you
look at CA all you need is the initial
condition and the and the rules and then
run the thing you
need three things you need the initial
conditions you need the rules and you
need time iteration to mine it out
without the coordinate you can't get it
out sure and that's that that to use
fundamental and you can't predict it
from initial conditions yeah if you
could then it'd be fine and that time is
a resource a foundation of uh the
history the memory of each the things
that created it has to have that memory
of all the things that led up to it I
think it's a yeah you have to have the
resource yeah because time is a
fundamental resource and and um yeah I'm
becoming I think I had a
major
um uh Epiphany about Randomness but I
keep doing that every two days and then
it goes away again it's random you're
you're a Time
fundamentalist you should be as well if
you believe in free will will the only
conclusion is there is time is
fundamental otherwise you cannot have
free will it logically
follows
well my my the foundation of my belief
in Free Will is just
uh is is uh observation
driven but that's I think if you use
logic it's
like logically it seems like the
universe is
deterministic looking backwards in time
and that's correct universe is